Ukraine's counter-offensive is winning
back hard-fought territory and some key
villages
but this is the hard truth of the war in
eastern Ukraine wretched fighting from
small trenches few gains and high
casualties on both sides
we hit them they hit us says this
Ukrainian Soldier
there are a lot of them he says too many
my fear says this Ukrainian is that
Russians will get to my home
that is the reality the Russian military
still controls much of eastern Ukraine
the Russian troops extend all the way to
the border with Belarus but a thousand
kilometers of front lines are in
Ukrainian territory the Ukrainian
counter-offensive hope to punch through
and cut off Russian supply lines but the
Russians are dug in there are many lines
of Defense with tank trenches and
minefields and the Ukrainian gains in
blue have been limited and there are few
signs that this grinding standoff will
soon change
the Russian strategy would appear to be
to sit on the defensive where the
ukrainians out
and then over time convince them that
this this is futile and also um I think
perhaps strategically perhaps more
important it's also to convince western
states that this is futile the
International Community must not allow
Russia to get away with this land grab
at the U.N Western allies one after
another pledged to maintain support for
Ukraine if Russia stops fighting there
will be no war
if Ukraine stops fighting there will be
no Ukraine but Poland has said it will
not send any more weapons to Ukraine
over a grain dispute and voices raising
questions about financing Ukraine are
growing louder in Washington we're very
concerned about accountability if
Ukraine doesn't make progress over the
next uh say 12 6 to 12 months I think
there are going to be there's going to
be additional pressure in the Western
World the ukrainians are counting on new
weapons and fighter planes to turn the
tide but Russia has announced that it's
increasing its military spending too and
it could go on for years and years and
years it's a match of political will at
some point uh political objectives need
to come into line with military
realities for now the military reality
is that Russia and Ukraine both have
sufficient resources to fight on Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto